[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis tout mon travail comme jumeaux
pourquoi ça
c'est quoi
volley gîte la burqa
vu comme et huawei ren mois que chanter
mais que faire
[Musique]
les
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je suis free wheels en vente ma vie ne
me demandez pas qui je suis
[Musique]
ouah
je suis un mois
hanouna oulala il est choquant matthew
tarisa hanouna
plus sexy qu'un chameau deuxième à alma
il s'agit toujours comme thala
les jeunes du 9-3 rémois le personnifie
l'originalité
[Applaudissements]
après
je n'ai pas
dis moi j'y suis tout seul au milieu de
la foule quand plus rien j'ai touché mon
coeur dis-le moi dis le moi tu souhaites
métro man on a tellement béchu que
j'étais pas grand monde c'est normal est
lobé mais des bases un jeu m'avait pas
y'a pas sur un avis paraisse de coups
avant
nous sommes emparés de données
mais sûrement sa demande et si tu crois
quoi
du jamais vu chez super man daily star
du r'n'b aux jo